- Welcome to The Kelly Clarkson Show.
Give it up for my band, y'all,
playing "Bad Habits" by Ed Sheeran.
(audience cheering)
- Yeah!
So we have someone on the line
who is very familiar with that song.
Can we say hi to him, everybody?
What's up, Ed Sheeran?
(audience cheering)
- Get it out.
Get it out, people.
They love you.
It is great to see you again.
I'm gonna lead with this.
It is absolutely terrifying
to be singing someone's song
and them listening while you're doing it.
I was like, "Oh my God."
I was like, "It's terrifying."
I love that song though.
"Bad Habits" is such a gem.
I love it.
Why did you write that?
- Thank you.
I loved your version by the way.
I was listening to your version,
wondering whether I
should have actually used
more electric guitar in it
'cause it sounded pretty great.
I wrote it
quite by accident?
I was working with
the two people that I made the
album with, Johnny and Fred,
and Fred is primarily
like a dance producer
and he played me a tune that
he was just about to release
that was a really,
really heavy dance tune.
And I just said, "You know what?
"Let's just try and make something upbeat
"That could also be
played on acoustic guitar
"Live basically."
And yeah, it just kind
of happened by accident.
I wasn't expecting it to be first single.
And yeah, it's one of these songs that...
It sort of came out, and
it's just kind of stuck.
And it's not like...
It hasn't been like my
biggest charting single,
but I think it'll end up
being one of my biggest
- [Kelly] Longevity.
songs just over time
very, very gradually.
- Yeah, that's longevity.
- That's the best kind of song though.
And also I didn't wanna freak you out,
but my idea was actually
to completely do it with just a piano,
and I wanted to make
it really dark and sad,
and then I didn't wanna freak you out.
So I kept it like this,
but I love a song like that.
I feel like you write songs like that.
That you can literally
do it with a huge band,
electric guitars, do it big.
You could do dance.
You could do singer songwriter.
I think it's an amazing
gift you have, songwriting.
Everybody knows that, but...
So you were a mega mentor
on The Voice this season.
Super stoked about that.
But I have to ask, who is
your favorite coach, Ed?
I mean, who is it?
Just shout it out.
Just don't
feel shy.
- Well, Kelly, only
one person...
Only one person gave me a gift.
(Kelly laughing)
- You're like,
"I can't say."
- [Ed] It must have been you
because I still actually...
I still have the jacket.
- See, I gave you
presents.
- I still have the jacket
in this house.
- I will buy your love, Ed Sheeran.
I will do it.